foreign  how good a woman your mama was  she took Colton Briggs the coldest  killer that I've ever met and she turned  him into a family man  I'm almost dead now  coming in one way or another  tell me the names of the men who did  this as long as that little girl is  alive  there's no room for vengeance  you're protecting a killer  from another killer  can you teach me how to shoot  yeah people do you put your hands behind  your back a Brig special  your father once you're done I'll blow  her brains all over this Valley  you ain't scared of nothing  Briggs decides he's coming  Grace is coming he's here sound like  he's the one who's scared  my whole life I'd seen fear in the eyes  the eyes of every man I ever happened  let's do this the old way is my father  still a good man  you boy [ __ ] up the devil  [Music]